Welcome to Super Family's 7th movie, The Toa Nuva.
Now we hope you enjoy this movie because this is our 7th and supposed to be our best.
Now here is Mandy Young.
I'm going over the rules.
Um, no cameras, like, to shoot pictures and stuff, no video cameras, no smoking, no
cell phones, no, um, no, turn all cell phones off.
Yeah, turn all cell phones off.
Thanks, Adam.
Um, you can only, like, the only thing that you can do with your cell phones would probably
be, like, if there's a part you don't like, you can't do it.
You can silent, you can play a little game on your cell phone without doing any, like,
noise.
And I think that's it.
Alright.
Enjoy the movie.
We now take you to the AC for the first part of our movie.
Enjoy it.
I'm going to go just, um, to my 162,000 word essay.
It's dizzy.
Anyway, Gal-Nuva's now in love with the new mask I got her.
Who's this one for?
Po-Ha-Tu-Nu-Va.
I just can't, I just can't remember, because, like.
They're so new.
Yeah, I'm not used to seeing them.
Uh-huh.
Hey, can you guess what day it is?
Saturday?
No.
TGF Friday?
TGI, Stacey.
It's...
Dr. Sneer's birthday.
Oh, I totally forgot.
Better hurry.
7 dot 6.
6 dot 7.
7-16 or whatever.
And I guess that's my schedule.
What?
It's 7-16, Stacey.
You might as well get that out there and start making the cake.
It's 7-16?
Um, I gotta get my book, and I gotta get dressed.
Alright, I'll be in the kitchen.
Okay, bye!
Court.
Oh, yeah.
Excuse me, I'm just doing some work for a senior.
And Mark?
I'm in a show. Well, Stacey's in it. I mean, that's my helper. But not today. Oh man, I could really be on TV right now.
Okay.
Hey, Stacey.
First, we take...
I was playing a TV show with the kids. That's why you heard that.
Yeah, I remember watching Toy Story 2. That was at the end. I wonder how they cut that off.
Anyway.
First, we take a blue cup with a strong touch.
Then, take a...
Hey, Stacey, are you making a cake for Dr. Snior?
Yeah.
Milk for the cup.
We shall move on.
And we will go to the little container.
It's 725.
They had some wicked potions and stuff that we're doing in the kitchen.
And it's...
We don't want...
We don't want to let you in there.
Okay.
So...
I'm going to head into the sunroom.
Okay. I'll see you in the training room.
Okay.
Let's take the barbecue sauce and pour it into the invisible milk.
Look at these three little rascals I picked up from the bedrooms.
I'm putting this...
Making Dr. Snior's cake.
This barbecue sauce in this invisible milk.
It's 727.
Yeah.
I think I can...
There we go.
Put this in a bit.
Amazing, isn't it?
My little sister.
Drop his lazy butt and come over here.
I'm kind of allergic to it.
I'm a tan.
Get yourself a drink.
I was just lying about the crazy potions.
I just didn't want you to know about the soup.
Well, the cake we split in.
And the pie wasn't made right, so we just made soup.
I'm going to get myself some iced tea.
I can guess why.
He was pulling...
He was helping pull in the wagon.
What are you doing?
Nothing really.
I'm just pulling with that circular box over there for years.
Yes?
It's terrible.
Now, I'm going to say this for the final time.
You're only supposed to call in this hotline if you're calmed down.
Oh, great.
Another different person.
Yes?
I'm going to go get my shoes.
Is this a serious matter?
Okay, now it sounds serious.
Sounds very serious.
Yes?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, this is the second call of the day.
Okay.
You don't need to tell me.
I already know.
Okay, what's this guy's name?
Ultimate Evil.
He's very dangerous.
What's his name?
Another call.
Yes?
Yeah, we'll take care of it.
He's back.
I never thought he would come to that.
The evil brother.
Yeah, I know.
He's back for revenge with the soul of Nakuda.
How'd we get him out?
What's up?
How'd we change him up?
I have no idea.
But, no, it could get in the A.C. to break him out.
I don't know.
He's pretty smart.
He's my twin brother, actually.
Please tell me not to eat a evil sister.
Let's get out of here.
We've got to go over there.
Come on, guys.
Let's finish up our dinner.
Okay.
We'll be the first ones out there, okay?
One.
Let's go.
We'll be there soon.
We'll get a wedgie, though.
Jigs.
Yomi said it.
Let's go.
We interrupt this movie to bring you this special report.
Uh, hey, we forgot to mention to you at the beginning that, um, there's a couple, uh,
there are new, uh, people in the Super Family.
They are Tahu Nuva, Gali Nuva, Kopaka Nuva, Anua Nuva, Lewa Nuva, and Gali Nuva.
And there's also...
Three Volkswagen New Beetles.
I know it's kind of weird because they're cars.
We call them Punch Buddies.
They're Blackie, Barry, and Ruby.
Right?
We will continue your movie.
My cuda.
I mean, evil brother, you will pay for what you've done.
What should I do?
Ha.
Evil sister, get down.
This...
You're not...
This is not your robot.
I'm in the shed.
And I'm helping, too.
My cuda.
Yeah.
I'm so good.
I've been missing out on this.
Remember the old days, don't you?
Yeah.
Bomb.
Watch.
A little tennis check.
Yes, Snakey.
Go.
Why aren't you attacking?
Or something.
Go.
I'm so good.
Your final beam.
Your kick.
You walk on camera, it's Alma and Sunflash.
That's not my dialogue.
You guys do his bite.
I'm getting bored.
What?
I'm going to sharpen my claws on this thing.
I only have one eye.
Your new shield, bro.
Alma, can you still fight?
You take the tail, dude.
I'll take the head.
Take the foot, dude.
Yeah.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Hey, dude.
That's right.
I like you.
Good thing we kept her from firing.
That's my most powerful attack.
No.
Not that it has big power.
Most powerful attack.
Now I'll knock out the next one before she uses her most powerful attack.
Bag of chips.
All that bag of chips.
Pingo, pingo.
Give me that pingo bag.
It's up, up.
Tail, dude.
Yeah.
I'll be right back.
Mm, so good.
Great.
Do it while I'm doing it while this one's sleeping.
I'm just a dentist in the morning.
Gotta get some sleep, you know.
Ha!
Stop it, Paul.
Stop scratching my head.
Good, I got the other one.
Ha!
Okay, that's a great one.
Most attack.
The most power.
Pinata.
No.
Spit kick.
There's your blindfold.
Thank you.
Oh.
Stupid thing.
Pinata.
No!
Your most power.
Baby Jess, get her.
Tch, tch, tch, tch.
Dancing to the music.
Okay.
I'm in.
What?
Hey, what's this?
Oh.
Why isn't she attacking?
She's getting proper position.
Ever hear of it?
No!
But I did.
Shut up, evil brother!
Lucky, Katie, yay, yay.
Big dad.
Why isn't she attacking?
You don't know.
Attack her!
You scared me.
Tickle, tickle, tickle.
Oh, that feels so good.
Oh, I guess she is fighting now.
Mew, mew.
Use confusion.
Meow.
Charge it up a little more.
And even hyper.
Use hyper.
Beep.
Ooh, she gets on my nerves.
Hang yourself.
Fat lumpy.
I hate you.
Ugh.
I'm sucking the collar from you.
Solar.
Retracting energy to solarize.
What solar do I need me now?
I'm pulling out light to fire a beam at you that will knock you out.
Like a potato chips.
Here you go.
I just made you taller.
Oh, wow.
Big and chubby.
Me fast, but me.
Now you're a cartoon.
Be chubby, but me.
I can't see you.
You used your most powerful attack.
Did you know me was born off a truck?
Guys, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Big.
Powerful.
And now you can see me.
But now you can't.
Use.
I got to tell you something.
Um.
Where's your mask?
Uh.
Yes.
I've defeated him.
Ah.
My most powerful attack.
Dragons.
Hey.
Give a doggy a little.
If the doggy behaves.
Give him a little crystal.
Discipline.
Get it?
Makuta.
I can see.
I have a bad problem.
Chew.
Sorry, Smith.
I was saying that.
I hope she doesn't fire her most powerful attack.
Thanks for reminding me.
Dragon.
Mindy.
Captain Teresa.
This is going to work.
This is going to taste like so good.
I'm going to take a nap.
Wake up.
Impressions.
Dentist.
Register in seven.
Be better than her.
In there.
You'll never defeat me.
Hit him.
I can't do that.
Why?
I don't know.
Okay.
Hey, dude.
We just started acting like kids.
She's not going to use her most powerful attack.
You're still not going to fire your most powerful attack.
It's because.
Attack her.
Never in me life like you ugly butt.
I'll make one.
Now maybe it was cartoon.
Oh, yeah.
Well, wait.
Scorchy wrote that on my bed.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Go.
Horn a minute.
The other one.
Scrape your nose like Gally does.
Yeah.
You're bald now.
Close your eyes.
I got a surprise.
Oh.
Your head.
That was four years ago.
Oh, well.
They must be the same today.
Hit him with.
In a cowboy gear.
Gear.
New kind of game.
The demon while trying to stay on the wicked ride.
First step.
Wait.
Radical music.
Okay.
Enemy roar.
Coke.
I'm not sleeping.
So I don't know what he did.
Car cast aside.
Then battle Con-Ra.
I'm kind of tired.
Some are.
We saved the day today.
They're defeated.
I guess we'll camp here.
Good night.
Told you guys.
Now take a taste of this.
Get up, Con-Ra.
You're going to get chilled if you don't wash your hands.
Watch it.
Yeah.
That's true.
Finally, Makuta's right.
Yeah.
For once.
Put his ear back on.
Maybe that's why he fell asleep.
It's the bazooka.
Mine's mine.
See?
I've been hanging it in my hip.
Con-Ra.
I'll get her tongue.
Oh, it's lame.
Yeah.
It's got lots of flies on it.
Flies?
I don't know.
Yeah.
There's some in my fur.
No!
Okay, Con-Ra.
Use your super attack.
Turn her into a cartoon.
A cartoon?
You're a cartoon now.
Ha ha ha.
You're a cartoon.
Ha.
Everything keeps like flashing on and off.
Now you're all fuzzy.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
I'm already fuzzy.
Get to the point why I'm here.
Okay.
My butt.
Stop it.
I hate when that flash is on and off.
Make me feel woozy like I am Cyan-Siamese if you don't please.
Uh uh.
It's Matthias and Cornflower.
That's Shark Claw.
A wing.
I can fly.
He's got to have his handy-dandy stupid wings.
Ready?
Catch ya.
Coming at ya.
And once and for all.
War.
Need something.
Plast.
I'll try to get it off.
Don't fool with it. It makes it harder.
I got a lightsaber though.
Ha.
Better than any old sword or anything.
It's the kids.
What's my name again?
It's Evening because this attack
works better in evening.
Mask of strength.
Pretty heavy.
Hey stop scratching my fake mask.
Would you do that?
My mask.
It's Sheila. Remember Sheila?
You're an Australian.
Who's been teaching you to talk
English accent?
You go like this.
Uh, what do you do
again? How do you
say it?
How do you talk?
What do you want me to say?
That's good.
Take their heads.
Hey!
Look at all this stuff I collected already.
Look what I collected.
I'll keep this here.
Boy, I wish I had that much.
Shoot.
Faster Sheila.
Maybe interrupting.
It's going to take more than one shot to get me.
Well try this.
It's the Powerpuff Girls.
It tastes like
whipped cream, dude.
I could suck on this all day.
Thanks Bubbles.
You're welcome.
Gotcha Buttercup.
I wonder if she tastes like a buttercup.
Your buttercup.
Good, now put me down.
What's the hyper mean?
Go Buttercup. Go Buttercup. Go Buttercup.
Your turn Bubbles.
Make it, you know.
Have a taste of this.
Use my most powerful attack.
I used my most powerful attack.
They are knocked out.
I hope they do not fire their most powerful attack.
See the hole in my back?
Yeah.
It's the Rowdy Ruff Boys.
Get them.
But you had to work on our landing.
Let's beat them one minute at a time.
I've hurt as much as this.
Now you're going to have to face me.
Go Mwaka.
Munchen, get him.
What you get for calling our stuff.
I have this little monkey.
Yeah, monkey.
I told you I'm the most powerful.
Who's going to battle me now?
I'll take care of these guys easily too.
We're more powerful than Mwaka and Con Ra.
Oh yeah? That's like a whip.
Challenge me.
Battle them.
I'm starting to feel tired.
That's a cheap way to lose.
It's Serena.
Get her.
That's stupid.
You never attack.
Feathery tag.
Use Hyper Ray.
Use Confusion.
Meow.
The block screen.
Block screen.
Itchy. Itchy. Itchy. Itchy.
Use my most powerful attack.
What was that?
Was that beak beam?
That stupidly...
That weak attack.
It's Louie.
Yeah.
Lightsaber.
Oh well.
What are you doing?
As long as I stay in this position.
Eagle Art.
yeah something zapping me and I don't know what it is
credit credit yeah what about me I will fool with you later
ha get her that's what you get for ignoring little old nuvock va
yeah right all right oh over the floor
thank you don't bother me is my cut if you don't know okay hurt you know that's
nothing compared to this we have failed evil Makuta and evil brother yeah you're
gonna have to because I can hang I'm hanging by my plate wait a second gotta
get a crown now we're gonna kick butt we rock yes yeah don't you remember yeah
buddy I bet you can
I bet you can
didn't last time I got a shielding chronic gonna have to go to my next
OOP mana my second crime I put in my looks like yours my last oh maybe it
we're going back to the time when it was the first movie you remember that
remember me movie this is my third one came out
until it can you say third one I had to put
in MICHELLE a hate this crime I need a
new head
I know this is my theme event please I
can bike I got one of your head you do
that force boy like E상 Kna glass
can get to me if good to they can you
guys do I might two hey let me at you
I'm a partner
frog for two o'clock guys totally but never stops until there's a track trailers with you want to learn I sure that's still a handsome kid dude, Andreann, swah, Ruth, art he vegetables, I am a smart guy now to play some years, I think you really suck but he's a good dog
She only, that's her last chrono.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Dung.
Spring.
What's that?
Oh.
Stomp, stomp.
Use the most powerful attack on the little one.
Now it's just the little one.
Plop, plop.
Tell him, I'm gonna pay for what you did to those other Bo-Rock.
I thought you knew your name, their names.
I do, but I'm gonna do this to you so bad.
And you, too, knock yourself out.
Uh, knock yourself out.
Looks like it's just you and me, Con-Rock.
Crunch, crunch, crunch.
That Maladon, I warn you, I'm trained in...
I can do that.
Come on, Pa-Rock, let's battle.
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
His questions are getting even more personal every day.
Should I say every minute?
That can't be right.
Well, I am mad.
If he asks that again, I'm not even answering.
Like I just did.
Not.
He's falling out.
How stupid.
I'm defective.
Before we do the first movie, get a different Power-Up.
Well, stomp.
Me, Lay-Bock, and Lay-Bock-Va battle first.
Oh, I wonder why how he's have to battle first.
Because, um, you're...
Okay.
Beefy.
Distances.
Well, I lost two Chrono already.
Yeah, it hurts, doesn't it?
Man, I got the hiccups.
I told Lay-Bock.
Power-Ball.
Blah.
It's a destroyer.
Oh, this is good, dude.
You should try it.
Because it's all mine.
Oh, so good.
This is good.
You should have tried it.
That's because you didn't leave me any.
Because I'm your brother.
You'd have to go to my next Chrono.
Kick butt.
With Lay-Bock-Va.
Yeah.
Lay-Bock-Va sword.
Yes.
Give back Lay-Bock-Va swords.
They don't really help me much.
But he's knocked down anyway.
But...
Let's get back in.
It's one.
It's my favorite one.
Bertana.
Since we've been out of our cases.
I know, but...
Did you know something, Makuta?
What?
All different types of Chrono.
Same kind of Chrono as I do.
If I have that kind, I'm gonna wear it.
You're gonna pay for that.
No, I'm not wearing my favorite Chrono.
I command you, Mwaka.
To take off that purple Chrono and give it to Galaf-Va.
Thank you.
Come again.
Wait a minute.
I gave it to him.
Oh well.
He took my Chrono.
I didn't give it to him.
That was easy.
Proof of my mouth.
Yeah.
Like Harry does.
Who's Harry?
That feels good, man.
Oh, I get that booger.
Get that booger in.
Yeah, so?
Head.
I got a head.
If you hurt me, you get a head.
You'll be a big fat rat.
A big fat rat.
Mm, that tastes good.
He's a tricky one.
I'm on my last Chrono already.
Gonna have to make it count.
Fire beam.
I guess not.
Fire can burn through anything if given the chance.
Hard to get out.
My second to last Chrono.
Daddy surgery.
Woke him up.
I can see.
My favorite Chrono.
Sometimes.
You're a meanie.
And meanies must be destroyed.
Ahh, well.
Yes, ma'am.
It's tonic.
Let's battle.
What about me?
Forget that word, anyway.
It's a hyper beam on here.
Yeah, good for me.
Ha ha.
Why don't I just say that?
I'm actually banging my head.
Explosive rock.
Since nobody else is doing it, guess not.
Get my head back on.
What do you do?
Scared, what do you do?
I get scared.
Scared.
No, I don't.
Shhh.
Bubblegum.
I'm not super.
And my one foot tore out.
I wish I could switch up, but I can't.
Oh, we got his head.
Rescue my head.
And don't use it as a soccer ball.
Shhh.
Look, I'm floating.
Okay.
I am floating a little higher.
This is hurting me.
I know.
It's a coaster.
Hmm?
Okay, this is like cool.
Poke.
Poke at me.
Fuck, I can't get out.
Hey, you know what?
What?
I'm taking your claws.
Hey!
Poke.
Now I'm going to turn into Super Pohatu.
I don't know what I can do with these things, but...
I'm cool.
I don't know what I'll really...
What these things will really...
Scrape.
Hey!
I should tell a thingy what...
Yeah.
I know.
I think it looks like shoulder plates.
Hey.
Yeah, yeah.
I forgot.
I'm probably asking for help.
Cracker tree을?
He品 to be carried.
Okay.
You deserve it.
You'll do well.
You've got this on him.
Okay.
Was he hiding for long?
I started the challenge.
Good.
Oh shit.
Okay I returning to the way.
I'm at the edge of kawaii liberty.
Aye.
Good.
So you want to do a super kick you missed.
Yeah.
Just a little dad joke.
That doesn't look like the center of the list.
uh, picks up the scooter. Anyways, I haven't picked a while to get this ready. Yeah, because
of big, fat slowpokes. You. So, I'm going to rest over here. We're back from our. Watch
out. You're really weak, so you got to watch it. Okay. One more time. I'm dead. I'm not
really dead. Just hours. Okay. That's him. That's Pohatu's attack. Oh, well. I'm going
to put these. Oh, good. Delicious. My mask. Only one more time. Pretty beat up, anyway.
What hacks did I use? What about ground beam? No, I already used that. Wait a minute. I
didn't. Crap, crap. Boom, boom, boom. Cool-ass sound effects. I haven't used this weapon
in a long time. I'm usually climbing. You're going to pay for that. Chomp. That's a gold
mask. I'm putting it back on. Ha, ha, ha, ha. All right. I knew it was underground planting
it.
Attack. What is it? Why would I tell you, Makuta? Put him in the air, bro. It'll take
him a while to get back. Ah, we beat them. Where's Lewa? Conrock threw him across the
field. Ah, he'll be back here in a couple seconds. What makes you think that? Well,
what should we do? Wait. Wait? What kind of idea is that? A good one. Later. I knocked
him out with a beam. No, you didn't. Well, now I am. I'm going to put him in the air.
Hail, but I won't. Head didn't fall off that time. Sharp in the ass. Monkey dance, tell
me how to do it. Power's up. Why would I want to tell you? Dude, ass. Let's do it with
you guys again since she's a girl. Okay, I guess. Hop, hop, hop, hop. Hey, Makita.
Shit. Make sure to be funny and annoying, Gally. Well, after these guys battle. I got
the fire staff. Ha, ha, ha, ha. I got to tell my sisters and, um.
Your little sister. Your pie holes, too. Make sure your pie holes are true. Be annoying.
Okay. My mask. He almost got it off. Pickety stick. Oh, well, it's battle. It's my pickety
stick. Aren't the two hungry going to battle, too? They have to get their masks. Uh, masks,
boy. Hey, I'm a karma. Sorry, boy.
Shut up. We're pink now. Okay. Two more. Want it? Oh, yum. For me. Mine did, too. Leave
you of your misery. Oh, thanks, dude. You're a real. Oh, yeah? Yeah, sure. If you want
to, I guess. I'm going to meditate. If you use it. Crunch. Ready? You take him. I've been.
For me. Like.
You know, like. It looks like you're really making our audience laugh. She's making this
audience laugh too hard. That's it. I laugh and that is very good for your body. So, since
it's very good for your body, you should be laughing. So, laugh, laugh, laugh, laugh.
Very good for you. Now, shut up. Play checkers. She didn't fire her most powerful attack.
Ha, ha, ha, ha. Neither did I. Thanks for reminding us. And my feet. We're getting old.
Too bad there's nobody else in the super family besides Dr. Senor that's, like, actually
young again. And besides the kids, that is powerful. Shhh. Do not. Confusion. Confusing
him with my twisted arm. Where's the blue? Look at my twisted arm. Yeah. Remember last
time. Hey, word. I'm going to get out something that Makuta hates. And the evil brother will
soon begin to hate. Cheese crunchies?
No, something else. That is it. That. No, not that. You mean that's not edible? You
mean. I mean something that, that is also what I thought you meant. Oh, the XO Toa. Oh,
yeah. Remember that one? See, that made Makuta sound like a girl. It just fits up his voice
box. Here, give me that voice box. Ah, I got it.
Student voice over
I'll just fix it up and
Please don't put
Here, let's see how he toxic now.
switched lines
I guess that's
I guess that's good.
Student voice over
Where is normal looking American on this page? Ah, there's no normal American. Uh. No
girl好
before
Please don't do that, Gally.
Daley
I'm so annoyed and proud of itข
cause I'm in the XO Toa.
Student voice G Además
之前
I'm ready now. You can't get me this is
Punch punch punch punch
Yeah, I'm trying something new and I don't think it's working
Wow
You're doing exact same thing galley does oh, you gave me a great idea turn it
We scratch his nose
10 shot right forward march
Okay, I ran
Yeah
Okay, thanks
Matches my color. Give it back. Oh, yeah
Feels up my cloud to be going to meditate
You don't need to meditate. Oh
Three o'clock three o'clock. I think beat grandma Pikachu's family. Yeah
You'll never defeat me
I know
It is
Kid is never gonna knock it out
Battling my week. I stopped this bottle again
Can't get after something I used to be make your voice box for that big purple
The exit toe was destroyed. What do we do now?
together
Or we can't do that. We're in big trouble because I just lost my weapon
Hey
It's water it needs smoke cuz you got my sister's weapon. We just lost your weapon. That's Makuta's tactic to turn us against
Hey, I'll go to the
Destroy him hyper beam. Ha ha ha ha
Take your voice back out. How'd you break it? I'm gonna use your shish kebab attack. Oh, we gotta go make some pancakes
I do do do happen on the grave
Ah
Good there's plenty more come hop it up. Please. There you go
Shish kebabs. Dang. It's only me
boom boom boom
There you go
Okay
In a minute, um, what do you want me to just give up?
She put on some weight there. I'm much more powerful than lewa, but you said you are lewa
That's because I am I was born four years ago on Christmas because I
What's your name
Ley one new bar nubuck it'll would do that. Oh, I gotta take care of him
Huh, you don't look much stronger than him. Anyway, just for two
Swords two swords, I'm scared two swords
Oh
and a new mouse.
Something like that.
Oh, I gotta kick your butt.
Catch him!
You missed.
Use the Hyper Beam!
This isn't right either.
Hit him with our most powerful attack.
Mr. Senor, I've gotta take care of the evil brother a certain way.
Me and him must go in a lightsaber battle
to determine who is the more powerful of the two of us.
You and the Toa Nuva take care of Makuta.
I'll take care of the evil brother.
Keep battling.
Okay.
Okay, I'm getting out to go battle Dr. Senor.
Makuta, take over.
Okay.
Your voice is sounding the same.
I've been at this job for a century.
I need the Toa Nuva!
Z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z-z
I thought I'm gonna use a more powerful attack,
I have an announcement to make before you watch a preview of Dr. Schneer's Battle.
This is taken from Star Wars Episode I Jedi Power Battles.
It's going to be, Dr. Schneer will be the one with the red, with the, wait a second,
with the blue and green bars under him, okay?
Now, on with the battle, where could the evil brother be?
Oh, here he is.
Where is he?
He just ran off.
What a coward.
Come and find me, Dr. Schneer.
Where are you?
Where did he go?
Where could he have gone?
Ooh, he's going to get it when I find him.
Hyper jump.
Right, there he is.
Better not knock me off the edge.
That was close.
I almost fell off.
Oh, get back here, you.
Looks like he's far away.
He's far away from now.
I'll have to catch up with him.
Maybe he went down here.
I'm going to have to find him.
I'll ride on this elevator.
I'll just wait here for a second.
We now continue the Tell-A-New-Lies fight for the Super Family.
Who is next to challenge me?
Yes, your name is Onua Uva.
See, I switched Mwaka and Con Ra and gave them new masks.
I see.
All right, get up.
Get up.
Get ready.
You know what?
I don't feel like battling too much today.
Charge up.
What at?
Farthest at you.
Powerful attacks.
Quick.